- Here's the thing, I wanna--
(shouts)
(laughs)
- Son of a (bleep)!
(mock shouts)
(hard rock music)
(grunts)
(bleep)
Oh!
(grunts)
- No!
- Oh, god!
("Filthy Red")
- We don't need these dumb instructions
these are useless.
- [Guy in Black] Yeah, right.
- What?
- I'm kinda worried about gutting this.
I feel like I'm gonna
catch a hot one in the eye.
- Hey, hey.
- (coughs) Got it in my eye.
- The guy I used to see
it, like, Brookstone,
those, like, nose hair trimmers?
- Yeah.
- Like I think that went,
like, (makes buzzing sound)
- Oh (bleep).
(bleep)
(laughs)
- A little, teeny, little splashy-poo.
- Pinterest bowl looks likes
(bleep) compared to that.
(camera shutter)
- Is this more fun than taking a shot?
(laughs) Yes.
Is this more efficient than taking a shot?
- [Both] No.
- Yo, if this was at a party, I'd leave.
("Filthy Red")
- I am totally aghast,
what we do with these.
- First off, if I'm having ice
cream, I don't want an apple.
- It's a lot of gutting things
and then putting things in other things.
- Just get a bowl.
- This is for someone that's just trying
to make their life more difficult.
- Yeah, you have to be really dedicated
if you want to make Pinterest
stuff for your party.
Oh no, I made a whole in it!
- Oh!
- I feel like you're
gonna break something.
- Oh, whoa!
- Jesus Christ, I wanna
kill myself with this thing.
- You know how I said I hated this before?
I kinda like it now
'cause this one worked out
and I'm pretty proud
of my accomplishments.
- Man, this is whack.
- Do people struggle making these things?
'Cause we just knocked it
out of the (bleep) park!
With the stem!
- Oh! Attention to detail!
(camera shutter)
- Oh, strawberry and lemon is disgusting.
("Filthy Red")
- Why?
- How are we gonna do that?
(grunts)
- We didn't even put
the masking tape on it.
- They've got decorations
and stars and things on this.
- Oh, we're gonna get some stars.
- I'm here for moral support right now.
- I thought Pinterest was much more about,
like, wedding dresses.
- Guys impress other guys
on the size of their grill.
- Yeah.
- Girls impress other girls
on the cuteness of their...
melons. (laughs)
That's how I ima--
- Why aren't you manhandling this?
We can't serve this at the picnic.
- You cannot pay me,
or you could pay me to do this.
- Yeah!
Bitch got a basket!
(whistles)
- I'm a proud gay momma right now.
So beautiful.
- [Guy in Red] Aww,
- [Guy in Red] stop it.
- The more you know.
- Is that a star?!
- Yeah.
(camera shutter)
- This sucked.
- I kinda liked it.
- We crushed it.
- I wanna almost take
pictures of what we did
and put them on Pinterest.
- Pinterest is not for
people who wanna cut corners.
It's people that wanna look cute.
- I make chicken parmigiana
out of cold pieces of chicken
and string cheese.
- I'd make a Pinterest
about how to cut the sleeves
off your shirts so you look bad ass.